warning this game contains bullying
kidnapping
torture murder no suicide graphic
violence
partial nudity kittens raw sewage cooked
sewage
microwave ready sewage true nightmares
eldritch monstrosities
bald assassins dk mode fake tans titans
murderous ice fairies impossibly strong
punches genocide crusades spooky scary
skeletons
standing on the edge
zombies vampires succubi lewd manga
busty pink haired schoolgirls
gamebreaking
how's it going bros and welcome to
yandere simulator the game
got updated and you know what that means
so actually what happened was that the
game got
banned on twitch.tv so you're not
allowed to stream this game
uh which you know what i can i
understand if you uh
i understand if that's what they want to
do but it seems that the developer
actually want to work with twitch and be
like all right what's the problem
maybe we can fix it because this game is
still very much in development
but the fact that twitch just decided to
ban the game completely with no
explanation and no
uh no chance to to
uh make any adjustments i think it's
kind of [ __ ]
uh so i hope twitch will change their
mind
but either way uh that's not gonna stop
this game from coming out
and let's uh check out the new features
what am i feeling today
i like these because if i [ __ ] myself no
one will know
let's do this uh town
is that still the same
okay they improved it a little bit look
at this
i love going to town it's my favorite
up the stairs never mind
up the stairs that's right this is how
you go upstairs
you shall not pass
[ __ ] you stairs you can't tell me what
to do all right here we go
come on stance
huh damn it ah
damn it come on come on
come on yeah
[ __ ] you steves all right where's the
school what the hell is this
um okay some water
what the hell oh okay uh okay
all right i think this is school holy
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
this space school the main thing is that
they added
personalities there's been personalities
before
but now they will react differently uh
say to someone getting stabbed
all right so oh [ __ ] it's sent by ah
what's up with her
nothing look at my ass i'm gonna i hope
he looks at my ass
she's acting strange yeah you look at me
walking up baby
yeah you like that hey they will react
differently to taking pictures
no they will still look terrifying
oh my god please guys i thought we had a
oh
yeah you see her she go away yep
i'm taking the picture don't worry hey i
wasn't done
[ __ ] okay why me there you go that's
gonna look great
so she is attention her social butterfly
same thing
okay and you are
okay i don't care excuse me
excuse me yeah oh my god is everyone the
same hello
hello oh no picture eh
she's evil so if we kill someone in
front of her
she won't interfere i like her sexy
don't tell much sam oh
you oh oh oh god no
who are these new people oh she she's
hateful isn't she
i still don't know who the [ __ ] this
[ __ ] is look at senpai
sitting by him tiff oh
he probably is so deep in that fur i
love him
i want to kiss his nipples he's perfect
in every single way
i'm going to caress his body who the
hell are you
greetings uh who are you
info no join club which club what do you
talk
drama okay you have joined the club
oh thanks
now i can wear socks wow that's nice
now i can fist senpai and we stare out
that's nice all right well enough of
this [ __ ] let's kill some [ __ ]
people
good night sweet prince so hey guys
how's it going everyone
no no i'm just on my period don't worry
about it hey what are you guys doing
after school
it works every time hey
sorry sorry i was just thinking about
but i am the stealth mess
what are these [ __ ] going to school
jesus christ
do they have nothing else to do baby
excuse me can i talk to you i apologize
i'm gonna get clean now that makes
perfect sense i guess
[ __ ] you tell me what's perfect sense i
mean i'll tell you
uh whatever oh god they don't see me do
they bam
bam all right so what is he gonna do
look at his [ __ ] face
hey no you ain't telling no one [ __ ]
hey i like your hair
oh [ __ ] she's fighting me
no
well i [ __ ] up you know what
i think you're cool yeah well you'll
never beat two
eye patches super mario cool
[ __ ] so right now
if i would for some crazy reason attack
one of these
she's going to be like it can't be
it can't be yeah that's right
hey guys immediately guys calm down down
there what's wrong with
death we need help right away and it was
oh god what is she doing i wonder who it
was
it wasn't super mario that's for sure oh
spaghetti
and there's the ones coward ones i think
like her
no wait there's some that are just
cowards and like no matter what happens
they will uh they will run to like a
group like a little
[ __ ] it looks like you [ __ ] his pants
ma'am
no no sensei i am a super mario
where is that luigi no no no no oh [ __ ]
of me
what am i doing hey what a dad here
hey who are you who are you greetings oh
god no
you are already in a club oops see
can't attack her what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] barbecue matt oh maybe there's
some
tools in the shed oh bleach
ooh sharp objects devin i can't use any
one of them
god damn it a glass house why the [ __ ]
would that be a glass house
hey [ __ ] you're trash all right well
that was gendari simulator
i really enjoyed playing this game it's
really fun i always look forward to new
updates
uh this one really added more of the
murder element to it
uh but uh i'm clearly not very good at
it
but either way thank you for watching
and leaving a like and
uh i'll see you brush as always in the
next video
it's a girls club oh this is this is
adorable look at this
so many awesome new stuff